Willkommen beim Chaosradio im Monat September. Hier spricht der Tim ausnahmsweise mal heute ohne unseren Lieblingsmoderator Johnny, der völlig elend gerade nach Hause gefahren ist und alle Verantwortung von sich gewiesen hat. Das liegt wahrscheinlich auch an unserem Thema heute. Es geht um die Verschwörungstheorie. Chaos Radio und der Computer Blue Moon. Einmal im Monat. Ich sag's mal gleich, im nächsten Monat, ausnahmsweise mal nicht im letzten Mittwoch im September, im Monat, sondern am 23.10. Und was es damit auf sich hat, das werden wir heute noch ausreichend erkunden. Ich nicht san chi. Ja Diesmal kann man sich ganz sicher sein. Das Fernsehen hat darüber berichtet und die Zeitungen sind voll davon. Augenzeugen werden zitiert und die Bilder sprechen eine deutliche Sprache. Jeder Zweifel wurde ausgeräumt und die Dinge stehen klar vor uns. Klar, klar wie Kloßbrühe. Alles ist anders. Habt ihr das nicht gewusst? Die Jungs vom Fernsehen sind auf einen falschen Reporter hereingefallen und die Zeitungen haben einfach alles abgeschrieben. Die Augenzeugen sind bestochen und das Filmmaterial lief auch schon letztes Jahr irgendwo auf dem Sender. Alles ist anders. Verschwörungstheorien sind überall da, wo die Wahrheit nicht überzeugen kann. Ob Kennedy, Titanic, Jim Morrison, Ötzi oder Estonia, jeder nahm seine Wahrheit mit ins Grab und übrig blieb nur Spekulation. Die wahre Weltregierung zieht wieder ihre Fäden und keiner hat's gemerkt. Verschwört euch mit euch, mit uns, mit Chaosradio. Das Ende ist nah.
No one would have believed in the last years of the 19th century that human affairs were being watched from the timeless worlds of space. No one could have dreamed we were being scrutinized as someone with a microscope studies creatures that swarm and multiply in a drop of water. Few men even considered the possibility of life on other planets. And slowly and surely they drew their plans against us.
Hallo bei Chaosradio, es fing schon mal wieder sehr chaotisch an. Ihr habt es mitbekommen, unser Hauptmoderator ist weg und jetzt müssen wir auf einmal alles selber machen, ganz unvorbereitet.
Schönen guten Abend, der Tim sitzt da, das muss man sich vorstellen. Der ist total aufgeregt, so aufgeregt, so aufgeregt.
Das ist alles eine Verschwörungstheorie. Okay, ich bin heute derjenige, der euch aufs Maul klopft. Das heißt, ihr müsst jetzt den Content bringen und ich kann mich rausreden.
Ja, so wie Johnny immer, jetzt wissen wir es auch.
Mit im Studio dabei sind die klassische Crew Frank, Stein und Anni.
Ja, so ein bisschen.
Und dann haben wir noch den Pluto draußen sitzen, der für uns heute die Medien mitverfolgt. Denn diesmal sind wir deutlich interaktiver, als wir das sonst sind. Wir hatten euch ja schon immer zahlreiche neue Versuche versprochen, mehr mit euch in Kontakt zu kommen. Diesmal sind wir online im Internet mehr oder minder dabei. Es gibt auf dem IRC, dem Internet Relay Chat einen Channel, Doppelkreuz Chaos Radio, ohne irgendwelche Bindestriche dazwischen. Dort sitzen Paul und Andreas und beantworten euch alle Fragen, die euch vielleicht zu dieser Sendung kommen. Wenn ihr also irgendwelche Anmerkungen habt oder vor allem wenn ihr irgendwelche Nachfragen habt zu dem, was wir hier erzählen, dann habt ihr die Gelegenheit, es dort zu tun.
Hat überhaupt irgendjemand eine Ahnung, ob die da ein Radio haben und mitvernimmt, was es geht?
Ja, doch, sie haben da vorhin eine hektische Installationsversuche vorgenommen und sich ein Radio installiert.
Die Technik ist perfekt heutzutage.
Ich höre doch nichts auf dem linken Ohr. Mein rechtes ist noch ein bisschen Vollwasser. Das liegt dran, dass du gerade aus dem Flieger kommst und da echt einen an der Waffel hast, oder? Nein, aber Moment, also das mit dem Flieger hat mit dem rechten Ohr zu tun. Also wenn ich den Kopf so 90 Grad nach rechts neige, dann geht das mit dem rechten Ohr. Und da ist der Kopfhörer auch in Ordnung, aber ich muss mir noch mal einen anderen Kopfhörer holen. Dann hab ich wahrscheinlich auch Akustik auf dem linken. Ach komm, Stereo ist sowieso ein neumodiger Scheißtreiber, ne?
Gut, kommen wir mal zum Thema. Es geht ja heute im Wesentlichen um Verschwörungstheorien. Thema hat's vorhin schon gesagt.
Das heißt, wir unterhalten uns heute um all die komischen Dinge, die irgendwie merkwürdig sind, die irgendwie so umlaufen. Nein, das ist überhaupt nicht wahr. Wir unterhalten uns darüber, wer wirklich die Fäden in der Hand hat.
Ja, ja, na, ist das nicht dasselbe? Wir wollen wissen, wer die Welt regiert.
Ganz genau. Das ist der Punkt. Aber wollen wir das wirklich wissen? Ja, ich bin nicht sicher.
Ich denke, wir werden am Ende ein bisschen mehr Klarheit haben. Jetzt fangen wir doch erst einmal mit den wichtigen Sachen an. Verschwörungstheorien. Verschwörungstheorien ist natürlich ein tolles Wort, aber da kann sich jetzt bestimmt mal wieder kein Mensch irgendwas drunter vorstellen. Wer von euch möchte mir dann mal bitte erklären, was er sich denn unter einer Verschwörung denn nun so tatsächlich vorstellt?
Also, als wir neulich beim Inda saßen, da hatten wir doch so eine Definition aufgeschrieben. Aber diesmal haben wir uns wirklich vorbereitet. Es fing irgendwie damit an, das sind ja zwei Worte, Verschwörung, was ist überhaupt eine Verschwörung? Ein konspirativer Verbund von Menschen, die irgendwie ein gemeinsames Ziel verfolgen, den anderen. Ein Geheimesziel. Ein Geheimesziel, genau. Also es könnte ja wohl auch ein konspirativer Verbund sein, der aber offenen Ziele verfolgt, aber das, was die Verschwörung auszeichnet, ist, dass das Ziel nicht offengelegt wird. Und die Theorie ist dann sozusagen die Aufdeckung einer solchen. Also wenn einem bestimmte Ereignisse in dieser Welt zwar in einem Zusammenhang zu stehen scheinen, aber irgendwie so ganz offensichtlich nicht, und wenn man darüber liest, irgendwie keiner hergestellt wird, dann fängt man eben an, Verschwörungstheorien zu entwickeln, wie es wirklich war. Wer also die Fäden in der Hand hat und das alles inszeniert hat und welche Interessen dabei man verfolgt. Und was dabei herauskommt, ist meistens viel plausibler als das, was einem die Medien als Wahrheit verkaufen möchten.
Also der interessante Aspekt dabei ist, dass Verschwörungstheorien jetzt nicht irgendwie ein erfundendes Wort vom Chaos Computer Club ist, sondern dass es weltweit natürlich unter anderem auch mal wieder im Internet zu bewundern eine sagenhaft große Verschwörungstheorien-Szene gibt, die fast jedes Ereignis mit entsprechenden Theorien begleiten. Stimmt das, Frank?
Ja, also eine kleine Suche nach irgendwie conspiracy-Servern im Internet hat dann doch irgendwie etwas zu viel erbracht. Ich konnte sie nicht wirklich alle sichten. Es gibt tatsächlich zu jedem Aspekt auf dieser Welt irgendeine Verschwörungstheorie und es gibt halt auch eine unglaubliche Anzahl von Sagen und Legendenkreisen zu diesen Verschwörungen, die alle doch ein Kern von Wahrheit enthalten könnten.
Das ist ja so das Ding.
Na gut, aber wir sollten noch bei der Definition kurz bleiben, weil wir hatten noch gesagt, wir müssen eine Abgrenzung machen. Wo ist sozusagen die Abgrenzung? Also die Frage haben wir uns auch erst mal gestellt zu sozusagen paranoider Schizophrenie. Also zu Leuten, die eine Verschwörungstheorie, die eine Verschwörungstheorie sozusagen nicht mehr als Theorie wahrnehmen, sondern als Realität. Weil es kann ja durchaus sein, dass wenn man eine Verschwörungstheorie entwickelt und der danach geht und das so anfängt zu prüfen und stellt fest, das ist wirklich so, dass man in seinem Weltbild dann dermaßen abgleitet und sozusagen sich in Inkompatibilität mit dem Weltbild der rätselichen Menschen, für Wohner dieses Planeten verhält, dass man eben für die als paranoide Schizophrenegestalt wirkt. Und was machst du denn da, Frank?
Wenn ihr behauptet, ich wäre nervös und würdet euch so Frank anschauen.
Nein, ich bin nicht nervös, du Mann.
Nein, du bist überhaupt nicht nervös. Du hast nur gerade sämtliche Flaschen mit Getränken, mit deinem Netzteil von deinem blöden Laptop irgendwie.
Ja, das Batterie ist alle, Herrgott.
Aber wir haben ja versprochen, diesmal vor allem den Hörern versprochen, dass wir diesmal beim Thema bleiben.
Und vielleicht auch auf und zu Musik spielen.
Aber ganz soweit wollen wir es noch nicht treiben. Bleiben wir doch nochmal bei diesen Verschwörungsdingen und diesen Verschwörungstheorien. Was zeichnet denn eine Gruppe aus, die nun verschwört? Also wer ist nun derjenige, über den man nachdenkt, wenn man über Verschwörungstheorien nachdenkt, wer sind jetzt die aktiven Personen, die dort im Geheimen ihren Wesen treiben?
Naja, ich denke im wesentlichen Sinn erstmal die Leute, von denen man einen vermuteten Nutzen sieht.
Also die, die diesen vermuteten Nutzen haben könnten.
Kannst du das nochmal im verständlichen, vollständigen Satz?
Es ist so, dass die Welt, so wie sie gerade ist im Moment, ist halt so komplex, dass man die meisten ereignet tatsächlich nur noch mit der Frage, wem nutzt es, durchschauen kann. Diese Frage, wer hat einen Nutzen von einem anderen?
Wer hat ein Motiv, das ist ja auch immer bei Kriminalfällen so eine ganz wichtige Geschichte.
Und dabei sollte man halt auch immer bedenken, dass die Dinge so komplex sind, dass wenn man denkt, dass irgendjemand einen Nutzen davon hat, könnte es aber auch sein, dass ganz andere Kräfte dahinterstehen, die nur so tun, als hätte irgendjemand einen Nutzen davon.
Ja witzigerweise, in der Wirklichkeit hat jemand ganz anderen einen Nutzen davon. Ich denke, wir sollten langsam ein bisschen konkreter werden. Diese ganze Geschichte hat ja in gewisser Weise einen, sagen wir mal, mehr oder weniger reellen Anfang und Bezug, zu dem wir ja auch allerhand gesammelt haben und den werden wir jetzt erstmal zum Besten geben. Es gibt da nämlich so eine Bewandtnis. Und zwar gibt es, sagen wir mal, eine Verschwörungstheorie oder eine Geschichte oder vielleicht ist es auch einfach nur so, dass nämlich die Welt in Wirklichkeit nicht von Politikern, von Staatspräsidenten, von Parlamenten, von all diesen Leuten beherrscht wird, sondern in Wirklichkeit von einer Handvoll Leuten, genannt die Illuminaten, es sind so fünf bis zehn Leute, die treffen sich alle paar Monate mal und wetten dann um einen Dollar oder vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr. Dass man also jetzt das und das irgendwie ansettelt, vielleicht ein Krieg irgendwo, und dass man dann die gegenseitigen Seiten mit Waffen beliefert und sich daran wieder dumm und druselig verdient. Und dass also sämtliche Politiker und Staatspräsidenten eigentlich nur Marionetten in deren Spiel sind. Und die kontrollieren halt die weltweiten multinationalen Konzerne und haben auch so ihre direkten Drehchen zu den verschiedenen Staatspräsidenten und spielen sozusagen dieses Spiel. Und die anderen, also die Präsidenten, selbst die glauben sogar, dass sie die Macht in der Hand haben, aber in Wirklichkeit ist das ein Riesenschmarrn.
Das ist jetzt aber deine Sicht der Dinge?
Na, das ist jetzt die Kurzvorstellung. Und Frank fängt jetzt nochmal kurz an, den Realanteil an dieser Geschichte, der nämlich gar nicht so gering ist, zu erläutern.
Jetzt kommt die Wahrheit.
Genau.
Schneidet euch bitte an in euren Sessel.
Wieso sieht die Welt so aus, wie sie aussieht? Diese Frage stellen wir uns spätestens im zarten Alter von 14 Jahren. Irgendwie scheint da etwas nicht mit den rechten Dingen zuzugehen. So wie es uns in der Schule erzählt wurde, kann es wirklich nicht sein. Tief hinter den dunklen Schleiern der Geschichte müssen verborgene Kräfte wirken. Mächte des Guten und des Bösen, die sich in einem jahrhundertelangen Zähnenring um die Macht befinden. Das Ziel der einen ist die Errichtung einer neuen Weltordnung, das der anderen die Erhaltung der Freiheit. Die Illuminaten, zu Deutsch Lichtbringer oder Leuchtete, sind in den letzten Jahrhunderten wohl einflussreichst dieser Gruppierungen. Nach einigen Quellen, schon seit dem Frühbeginn der Menschheit aktiv, benutzen sie eine unzahlen Frontorganisationen, um ihre Zwecke zu verfolgen. Ihre Fallen unterstellen ihnen folgende Ziele. Entsorgung von Regierung, Privateigentum, Erbschaften, Nationalismus, Familie, Religion, Heirat, Moral und Kindererziehung. Das geheime Machtsystem der Illuminaten beruht auf einer pyramidalen Macht, auf einer pyramidalen Struktur mit 13 nach anderen Quellen 17 Stufen. Die geheimen Organisationsdiagramme der Illuminaten beruhen auf einer Pentagrammstruktur. Das heißt, dass es immer 5 Kontrollfunktionen gibt, die wiederum 5 andere Funktionen kontrollieren. Der Trick dabei ist, dass man mit 5 Elementen bis zu 120 Verknüpfungen herstellen kann, und das kann kein Mensch mehr überblicken, wenn man nur 4 hätte. Dann könnte man maximal 20 Verknüpfungen herstellen. 1776 wurden die neuzeitlichen Illuminaten von Adam Weishaupt gegründet, und zwar aus einer unterwanderten bayerischen Freimaurerloge. Zu den Freimaurern kommen wir dann später noch. Sie gewannen schnell an Einfluss unter mächtigen Zeitgenossen, weniger mächtigen Zeitgenossen. Einer der bekannten Mitglieder war zum Beispiel der für die deutsche Moralerziehung so wichtige Freiherr von Knigge, der dieses unsägliche Buch der Knigge verbrochen hat. In den USA wurden sie so mächtig, dass sie zum Schluss sogar ihren Leitsatz, Novus autose Clorum, die neue Weltordnung und ihre Machtstruktur, die Pyramide mit dem alles sehenden Auge auf den Dollar-Schein drucken konnten, um aller Welt zu zeigen, dass sie gewonnen hatten.
Jede 1-Dollar-Note trägt sozusagen das Symbol der Illuminaten und wer jetzt eine zu Hause hat, kann sich das angucken während der Musik. Ich glaube, da steht sogar noch das Datum mit unten bei. 1776 ist da genauso vermerkt wie die 17 Stufen der Pyramiden.
Das sind da glaube ich 13 auf dem Dollar-Schein.
Zählt mal nach, ruft uns nachher an. Ja genau, aber lasst uns doch erstmal die Musik spielen, und derweil die Pyramidenstufen zählen.
Die Illuminaten, die Lichtbringer, die Erleuchteten. Das war natürlich jetzt eine ganze Menge Information von Frank. Das muss man gleich noch mal ein bisschen nachhaken, damit das auch verständlich ist. Woher leitet sich denn dieser Name ab? Also haben die sich selber diesen Namen gegeben oder ist das...
Also der ursprüngliche Name war ja die Illuminierten oder die Seeer von Bayern.
Die alten Illuminierten Seeer von Bayern war der Name der Loge, die Weißhaupt gegründet hat. Und naja, es gibt halt schon länger irgendwelche Gruppen, die halt als Illuminati oder Illuminaten bezeichnet werden. Es gibt auch unterschiedlichste Zweige, die behaupten, die echten Illuminaten zu sein. Also es ist verwirrungsschändlich.
Aber fangen wir mal vielleicht mit den Freimaurern an. Das waren ja sozusagen die vorgehenden Institutionen. Das waren also Verbünde von Handwerkern, also von sozusagen ganz normalen Menschen, die sich überlegt haben, dass man doch irgendetwas dafür tun könnte, das Bewusstsein der Mitmenschen etwas zu erweitern.
Ja, es fing ursprünglich damit an, nicht irgendwie das Bewusstsein zu erweitern, sondern die Arbeitsbedingungen etwas zu verbessern. Also ganz ursprünglich war es so was wie Frühgewerkschaften, die aber relativ schnell zu spirituellen Gewerkschaften wurden, wo es tatsächlich darum ging, halt Bildung und Bewusstseinserweiterung unter die Menschen zu bringen.
Sozusagen das fundamentale Gegenteil von heutigen Gewerkschaften.
Und diese Bünde zogen auch relativ schnell Leute an, die nicht unbedingt an Handwerkertätigkeiten interessiert werden und entwickeln dann relativ schnell ein System von Logen und Zweigen, die sich dann auch die unterschiedlichsten Namen gaben.
Was muss man sich unter einer Loge vorstellen?
Eine Loge ist ein Bund von meistens Männern, die sich gar nicht wahr... Doch, die alten Freimaurer-Logen bestanden ausschließlich aus Männern. Wahrscheinlich wird dann irgendwann wieder eine Freimaurer anruft und sagen, das ist jetzt aber heute nicht so und jetzt können auch Frauen mitgehen. Und diese Loge ist sozusagen so was ähnliches wie ein Club, in dem sich die Leute regelmäßig treffen und Bildung erfahren. Und zwar vor allen Dingen auch durch sogenannte Initiationen. Das sind Handlungen, die kann man sich vorstellen als Weihrehandlungen, die aber meistens doch mit einer etwas krassen Erfahrung für den Kandidaten verbunden sind, die ihm zu neuen Erkenntnissen über die Welt und sein eigenes Bewusstsein verhelfen sollen. Und man geht da nach und nach durch eine Anzahl von solchen Initiationen, die bis zum 33. Grad mittlerweile unterteilt sind. Und damit steigt dann auch die Machtposition innerhalb der Loge.
Gut, und ich meine, abgesehen von den technischen Daten, warum wir dieses Thema aufgreifen oder warum wir jetzt die Illuminaten vorstellen, das hat natürlich auch damit zu tun, dass irgendwann mal ein Mensch namens Robert M. Wilson ein Buch geschrieben hat, Illuminator ist ein Dreibänder. Ein Roman, der eben sozusagen von den Illuminaten und vielmehr vom Kampf gegen die Illuminaten handelt. Also der Titelheld ist Hekbert Zellein, ein Mensch, der einmal ein U-Boot geklaut hat, ein gelbes U-Boot, das er aus einem Pop-Song entwendet hat. Abgesehen davon hat er eine biologische Waffe an Bord, die er also aus einem amerikanischen Waffenlabor geklaut hat und die ihn sozusagen zum freisten Menschen der Welt machen. Das zeugnet sich antragsblau und das ist ungefähr das Herbst. Und was die jeweils hervorgebracht haben, wenn er das also an die Wasseroberfläche lässt, dann ist das Leben auf diesem Planeten innerhalb von Minuten ausgelöscht. Und da die Amerikaner schlecht zugeben können, dass sie sowas niemals in Auftrag gegeben hat und auch auf der anderen Seite sich ungern mit ihm anlegen möchten, lassen sie ihn also in Ruhe. Und alle anderen Regierungen dieser Welt lassen ihn auch in Ruhe. Und er schifft also so durch die Weltmeere und fristet sein Dasein mit der Legion des dynamischen Diskords. Und die Legion des...
Dieses Buch, inwieweit hat denn das nun einen konkreten Bezug zu der tatsächlich bekannten und dokumentierten Geschichte der Illuminaten? Und inwieweit ist das nun eine freie Weitergeistung?
Ja, das ist sozusagen die Aufgabe des Lesers herauszufinden, aber das ist eine schwierige Aufgabe. Weil dieses Buch, eine Mixtur aus einer Geschichte, aus geschichtlichen Handlungen und Zusammenhängen ist. Und ich befürchte, dass der Autor auch eine Menge Haschisch geraucht hat, als er das Buch geschrieben hat. Das ist nicht so ganz nachzuvollziehen. Aber die Idee, die da prinzipiell ist, und die möchte ich kurz vorstellen, ist eben sozusagen dieser ebenfalls mehr oder minder konspirative Verbund der Legion des dynamischen Discords, den ich nach den Nachrichten, die mir hier durch mir bekannte Handzeichen, die ich nicht mehr erläutern möchte, zu verstehen gegeben wird.
Die Kommunikation funktioniert im Chaosradio. Ich hab dich leider gnadenlos unterbrechen müssen für das Fritz-Info. Ich teile dir von daher auch sofort wieder das Recht zu sprechen.
Also gut, ich fang noch mal ein bisschen von vorne an. Es gibt also nach diesem Buch, nach dem Illuminatusspruch von Robert M. Wilson eine Gruppe, die sich den Kampf gegen die Illuminaten, gegen die Weltverschwörer zum Ziel gesetzt hat, den Legion des dynamischen Discords und die Grundannahme desjenigen, der diese Legion betreibt, ist also das nicht die Welt, wie viele Menschen glauben, sich in Rationalisten und Irrationalisten teilt, sondern dass in Wirklichkeit alle Menschen irrational sind, in unterschiedlichen Grades und dass sie sich viel mehr aufteilt in Menschen, die neuen Dingen aufgeschlossen sind und die neuen Dingen verschlossen sind. Das sind dann die sogenannten Homo-Neophil, also neuen Aufgeschlossenen oder Homo-Neopoben, die den neuen Dingen verschlossen sind und eher konservative Wertvorstellungen beherbergen. Und ja, und jetzt war eigentlich dein Einsatz, Frank, aber gut, dann muss ich wohl weiter sabbeln. Und er sozusagen bereist also diesem Planet mit seinem wie gesagt gelben Unterseeboot so daher, schmuggelt Drogen, weil er also der Meinung ist, dass keine Regierung dieser Welt das Recht hat, Handel einzugrenzen und überhaupt die Freiheit des Menschen einzugrenzen und das in Wirklichkeit diejenigen, die also Beschränkungen vornehmen, nur das Beste für sich wollen, um es mal kurz zu fassen. Und ja, naja gut und das Buch geht dann so seine Geschichte, es kommt dann so zu verschiedenen geschichtlichen Hinweisen, was die Illuminaten also schon alles angerichtet haben und im Laufe des Buches wechselt zu sein das Feindbild auch jegliche Vorstellung. Also es geht gar nicht so sehr darum, ob jetzt hier kommunistisch links, rechts, oben oder unten, sondern er ist also der Meinung, dass eigentlich das alles nur verschiedene Mäntel sind, verschiedene Etiketten vereinen und dieselbe Sache. Also ganz egal, welcher Ideologie die Leute anzuhängen glauben, in Wirklichkeit sind das alles nur die Illuminaten.
Gibt es denn eine konkrete Vermutung? Ich meine, wir reden ja nicht nur über Verschwörungen, sondern wir reden ja auch über Verschwörungstheorien. Gibt es denn eine konkrete Vermutung, wer diese Illuminaten denn nun konkret in dieser Welt sind? Also von wem reden wir eigentlich? Du hast vorhin gesagt, das sind fünf oder sechs Leute. Das ist ja schon eine ziemlich naheliegende Vermutung.
Ja, ich kann jetzt theoretisch sogar ein paar Namen nennen, die ich also im Verdacht habe, die also im Moment sozusagen maßgebliche Menschen sind, die auf diesem Planet eine bestimmte Entwicklung vorantreiben. Dazu gehört zum Beispiel der El-Gor, der Präsidentenberater von Onkel Busch, ne wie heißt er? Clinton im Moment. Also des amerikanischen Präsidenten, der also ja nicht nur als Präsidentenberater, sondern auch in sonstiger Funktion als Wirtschaftsberater also eine Menge Entwicklung gepusht hat, gerade im Bereich Computer, Daten, Autobahn. Dieser Information Highway Begriff stammt ja von ihm und er hat da sozusagen eine Lavine und wirtschaftliche Entwicklungen losgetreten. Andere Leute munkeln, dass er eben in so einem Verbund steht mit jemanden wie Kevin Kelly, der also die Wired betreibt, mit jemanden wie Bill Gates, der wohl hinreichend Begriff ist durch sein Software Imperium, aber auch mit jemanden wie John Perry Barlow, der also eigentlich als Kritiker oder als Kritiker beobachter dieser Entwicklung als Philosoph praktisch unterwegs ist. Er war früher der Songtexter von, wie heißen die? Grateful Dead. Genau, bevor er Pharma war. Mittlerweile ist er sozusagen wandelnder Philosoph und er ist also derjenige, der unter anderem diese Internetunabhängigkeitserklärung geschrieben hat unter dem Motto, das Internet erklärt jetzt den Regierungen dieser Welt, den Krieg, wir brauchen euch nicht mehr, denn wir haben die Informationsfreiheit gepachtet und so weiter und so fort und also seine gar nicht mal unrealistische Vision ist es, dass eben durch globale wirtschaftliche und informationstechnische Zusammenhänge, dass also sowohl die multinationalen Konzerne als auch das Leben auf der Datenautobahn, auf dem Internet unsere und so weiter und so fort viel mehr das Leben der Menschen bestimmen wird als irgendwelche nationalen Regierungen, dass also im Prinzip nationale Regierungen überflüssig werden und das ist natürlich, wenn man so will, der erste Schritt in Richtung einer New World Order, also eines neuen Paradigmas, wo es dann wirklich nur noch die Weltregierung gibt und diese Illuminaten vielleicht gar nicht mehr im Verborgenen herrschen, sondern ganz direkt. Andi, du ich hab mal jemanden sagen hören, du kennst all diese Leute versöhnlich. Ach, das ist alles nicht wahr. Aber ich hab diesen, also wie ich jetzt auf meine ganz konkreten Vermutungen komme, das hat eine kleine Geschichte. Ich hab diesen Balo mal auf einer Veranstaltung getroffen in Düsseldorf und wir haben uns also beim Abendessen etwas unterhalten und dann haben wir irgendwie Physikkartchen getauscht, wie man das halt tut, irgendwie dieses komische Ritual und auf einer seiner Physikkarte fand ich eben genau dieses Symbol der Pyramide mit den 17 Stufen und dem Auge oben, also genau das Symbol, was sich auch auf der Daulernote befindet und was eben auch in der Literatur hinreichend als das Symbol der Illuminaten identifiziert ist. Und ich sagte zu ihm so mehr im Scherz, ja hier auch Wilson gelesen und so, Illuminatus und so und er meinte, ne ne, nicht Wilson gelesen, ich bin einer der Illuminaten. Und das meinte er vielleicht halb im Scherz, aber so weit hergeholt ist das gar nicht, wenn man sich überlegt, mit was für Leuten der Mann sozusagen in seinem, also da besteht tatsächlich so eine Aktion, auch bekannter, mehr oder weniger konspirativer Wirtschaftsverbund, wo sich also bestimmte Leute treffen, die nicht unerheblichen Einfluss darstellen und sich also überlegen, wie sie jetzt irgendwie die Entwicklung weiter treten und wie sie jetzt sowohl philosophisch als auch wirtschaftlich als auch sonst wie weitermachen.
Naja, also ich glaube, dass der Kontext von deiner Illuminatengruppe ist glaube ich zu eng gefasst. Ich denke, dass die wirklichen Illuminaten wahrscheinlich sowas sind wie der Herrscher der Welt in Davids Adams Roman, der in seiner Planetenhütte im Regen sitzt und seine Katze streichelt. Oder dass sie halt bei den Banken sitzen, bei den Leuten, die das Geld kontrollieren, die das Geld um die Welt schieben, die Leute, die die Investment Trusts kontrollieren, die in der Lage sind, beliebige Mengen Geld von einer Wirtschaft in die andere zu pumpen.
Das ist nicht subtil genug.
Diese Verschwörungstheorie ist sehr subtil.
Also philosophieren und theoretisieren wollen wir im Wesentlichen in der nächsten Stunde. Wir wollen uns jetzt noch mal in dieser ersten Stunde darauf beschränken, die Hintergründe dieses Verschwörungskultes zunächst einmal plastisch darzustellen. Das tun wir natürlich nicht zuletzt deshalb, damit wir jetzt unsere Hörer, also euch, an den Empfängern auffordern können, selber mal eure Gedanken langsam brutzeln zu lassen und mal darüber nachzudenken, ob denn nun eigentlich alles stimmt. Ich meine, ihr guckt nun jeden Tag Tagesschau oder welches Medium ihr auch immer bevorzugt, manche vielleicht auch eher Internet und gerade dort...
Die Netscape Zeitung.
Die Netscape Zeitung, genau, Netscape Allgemeine. Habt ihr euch eigentlich schon mal Gedanken darüber gemacht, ob denn das nun eigentlich alles stimmt. Wir werden also in der nächsten Stunde ein konkretes Beispiel herausgreifen und wir wollen euch motivieren, das zu tun. Rückmeldung grundsätzlich nach wie vor auch über das Internet per E-Mail an chaos.orb.de. Wir lesen die Mails dann hier auch. Und ihr habt die Möglichkeit im IRC jetzt in diesem Moment in dem Channel Chaos Radio selber aktiv teilzunehmen und dort bei Porn und bei Andreas nachzufragen, falls ihr besondere Details noch mal genauer wissen wollt.
Und nach der Musik würde ich vorschlagen, gehen wir noch mal kurz auf die Grundthesen und die Techniken ein, bevor wir dann auf die konkrete Frage nach der Wer hat die aktuelle Verschwörung in der Hand eingehen?
So, jetzt werden wir von unserer eigenen Planung wieder überholt. Eigentlich wollten wir euch zu den Anrufen erst in der nächsten Stunde aufrufen, aber wir haben jetzt schon einige Anrufer und die können wir natürlich unmöglich ablehnen. Ähm, holen wir uns doch mal die Leitung 3 rein, die 4 rein, die 4. Hallo Felix?
So viel dazu.
Hallo Felix? Bist du noch da, Felix?
Etwas energischer bitte.
Die 5 vielleicht? Bist du Felix? Ich glaube, du bist nicht Felix. Du bist Felix?
Ja, ich bin Felix.
Hallo Felix.
Hallo.
Ich wollte eigentlich dazu sagen, zu der Verschwörung, wo ihr am Anfang der Sendung wart, dass ich auch schon mal, dass ich meine Klasse, dass ich meine Klasse gegen mich verschworen hat.
Wo ich doch da vorhin auch diskutiert hab drüber.
In welchem Ziel?
Ja, ich bin ziemlich der Außenseiter. Ich gehe in Dichtenberg auf eine Schule, da rennen sie alle ziemlich nazimäßig rum.
Nochmal den Radiolaser bitte.
Ja, Moment, warte.
Fiep ich immer noch?
Ja, und ich bin der einzige mit grünen Haaren.
Und da gehen sie sich irgendwie dagegen stellen.
Da meinte doch die Klasse einmal irgendwie, dass sie sich jetzt mit mir nicht mehr spricht. Und alles sowas, die haben mich dann von jedem was angesagt war ausgeschlossen.
Und haben sie sich auch konkret verschworen? Also haben sie auch bewusst Maßnahmen eingeleitet, die dir jetzt nicht zugutegekommen sind?
Na ja, das klingt so wie die kleine Weltverschwörung zwischendurch.
Verschwörung findet auch immer im Kleinen statt.
Also ja, zum Beispiel meine besten Freunde in der Schule, die waren dann auf einmal nicht mehr meine Freunde, echt. Also so zum Beispiel.
Alles klar. Okay, du bist also ein Opfer einer Verschwörung geworden?
Ja, genau.
Na gut. Ja Felix, und danken wir für deinen Anruf. Dann haben wir noch den Simon. Simon, hallo? Ja, ich wollte noch was zum Bayerische Illuminati sagen.
Also die Bayerische Illuminati stammen nicht von der Bruderschaft der Schlange aus ab.
Sondern?
Also wir hören dich noch.
Simon, wir hören dich noch.
Nein, jetzt hören wir ihn glaube ich nicht mehr. Simon, du kannst ja noch mal anrufen. Das Thema war toll. Frank, hast du mitbekommen?
Ja, das Thema war sehr interessant. Einige Quellen in der Literatur sagen nämlich, dass dieser Frühbeginn der Menschheit tatsächlich im alten Babylon lag, wo es eine Bruderschaft der Schlange gab, die von den Illuminaten unterwandert wurde bzw. von anderen Organisationen unterwandert wurde. Und dass es seit da diesen ewig werdenden Kampf der Geheimgesellschaft der Neophoben gegen die Geheimgesellschaft der Neophilen gab. Ja, also da gibt es viele Quellen und verschiedene Ansichten. Es gibt wie gesagt auch eine Quelle, die gerade Simon zitierte, dass die bayerischen Illuminaten nichts mit der Bruderschaft der Schlange zu tun hatten. Schwer zu entscheiden.
Ja gut, ich denke, das ist aber noch nicht das Entscheidende, weil, Hörer, machen wir nachher. Also mit den Anrufen, da kommen wir gleich noch mit einer Frage. Wir wollten jetzt erstmal in der ersten Stunde das Thema ein bisschen einläuten. Und dazu haben wir einige Grundthesen entwickelt, die euch vielleicht helfen können, sozusagen die Theorie, die Verschwörungstheorie oder die Theorie der Theorien zu verstehen. Das ist das falsche Lied übrigens. Also entweder Ich hab mich vertan oder es ist nicht die 11, die ihr da spielt. Versucht es mal mit der 12 oder der 13. Also die Geschichte der Welt ist die Geschichte des Kampfes zwischen geheimen Gesellschaften. Das ist sozusagen die These 1, die dem allen zugrunde liegt. Die These 2 ist nichts ist so, wie es zu sein scheint. Die These 3 ist Wissen ist Macht, aber durch viele Informationen entsteht noch lange nicht Wissen.
Was?
Ich soll entsprechen zum Mikrofon. Ja, aber ich wollte auch diese Hintergrundmusik, irgendwie ist die Technik heute...
Die Technik macht das zum ersten Mal. Rede einfach weiter, wir kümmern uns drum.
Gut. Die These 4 ist es ist nicht schlimm nichts zu wissen. Schlimm ist es nichts wissen zu wollen. Und die daraus resultierende These 5 ist die Wahrheit ist eine Glaubensfrage.
Verschwörungstheorien auf Chaosradio. Die erste Stunde widmet sich dem Hintergrund des Verschwörungskomplexes, der Machtkomplexe auf dieser Welt. Wir hatten tangiert die Illuminaten, die Freimaurer, die Logen, die Geheimbünde, die sich zusammentun, um im Hintergrund ihre Machtgespenste zu entflechten und aktiv werden zu lassen. Nun sind natürlich die Illuminaten und vor allem auch ihre Vorgänger und Nebengänger, die Freimaurer, natürlich nicht die einzigen Organisationen, die auf diesem Planeten konkrete Macht ausüben. Nennen könnten wir da sicherlich noch viele und das werden wir sicherlich auch noch tun. Wen müsste man denn nun, wenn man von Illuminaten spricht, auch noch mit erwähnen, Frank?
Naja, den Vatikanen. Der Vatikanen ist ja, wie ihr alle wisst, ein eigenständiger Staat auf den Territorien von Italien, der halt in eigener Regie eine Nationalbank hat, die weltweit sehr weite Verbindungen hat und der natürlich seine eigene Politik im Namen und im Auftrag der katholischen Kirche betreibt. Die katholische Kirche ist ja nun mit einem Alter von knapp 2000 Jahren eine der ältesten Organisationen auf dieser Welt und von da auch eine der mächtigsten Organisationen. Es gibt viele Geschichten zum Vatikan. Eine der interessanteren ist, dass der Vatikan ist tatsächlich geschafft hat, aus der Geschichtsschreibung einige hundert Jahre zu entfernen und sich mittels mithilfe dieser Manipulation in der europäischen christlichen Geschichtsschreibung beträchtliche Ländereien zu sichern.
Welche Jahre sind denn das?
Na ja, sie sind irgendwann zwischen 1000 und 1500 und da ist es so, dass es Leute gibt, die behaupten, wenn man diese, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, es waren 300 oder 400 Jahre, wenn man die halt wieder einfügen würde in die Geschichte, dann haben wir längst das Jahr 2300. Ja genau, nein, dann wurden vor allen Dingen diese komischen Tabellen widerstimmen, mit denen man heutzutage diese Altersrückdatierung machen muss. Da gibt es so Eichkurven, obwohl es eigentlich ein physikalisches Verfahren ist, muss man da halt immer noch eine Korrektur anwenden, damit die Urkunden widerstimmen. Zu dieser Zeit gab es große Verwerfungen in Europa, da haben halt die Katholiken mit Macht alle anderen heidnischen großen Gruppierungen halt ausgerottet. Und einerseits um das zu vertuschen, andererseits um sich Grundstück zu sichern, soll so der Verschwörungstheoretiker der Vatikanen diese Sachen manipuliert haben.
Ja, wobei, also ich finde den Begriff Verschwörungstheorie in diesem Zusammenhang mindestens abwertend, weil damit sagst du ja, das ist ja nur eine Verschwörungstheorie. Das ist ja so, als wenn du sagst, das sind ja nur paranoide Schizophrenen, die das behaupten.
Naja, also die Theorie könntest du ja nur dann weglassen, wenn du konkret beweisen kannst, dass der Vatikan Dreck am Stecken hat.
Tim, was ist dein Beweis?
Ja, also ich meine, dass der Vatikan Dreck am Stecken hat, das ist nun klar. Oder nicht?
Naja, es gibt ja immer noch diese schönen vatikanischen Archive, die ja nicht so unrecht wahrscheinlich als einige der interessantesten der Welt gelten und zu denen der Zugang extrem begrenzt ist. Also es gibt da halt so einen öffentlichen, so einen halb öffentlichen und einen überhaupt nicht öffentlichen Teil und im Rahmen des Vatikans bekämpfen sich auch wieder verschiedene Fraktionen. Die bekannteste und älteste sind die Jesuiten. Interessant am Rande ist vielleicht, dass Adam Weishaupt, der Gründer der Illuminaten, auch Jesuit war und von Jesuiten erzogen wurde. In neuerer Zeit hat die Rolle der Jesuiten der Opus Dei eingenommen, eine erzkatholische, christliche Geheimorganisation, die sogar das Placee des Papstes hat, irgendwie diverse Dinge zu tun, die mit den Finanzen des Vatikans zu tun haben. Das ist halt ein weiter Kontext.
Im interessantesten ist, dass dieses Archiv, denke ich mal, im Vatikan, es gibt glaube ich nur ein Archiv oder gab ein Archiv, das noch interessanter war als dieses und das war das alte Archiv von Alexandria, das angeblich, so behauptet die Sage, abgebrannt ist seinerzeit, wo das jetzt steckt, würde mich eigentlich mal interessieren.
Wenn jemand anrufen könnte und uns das erklärt, das wäre toll. Okay, jetzt haben wir die Illuminaten gehabt, es gibt viele Beweise oder Andeutungen dafür, dass die Illuminaten als Gruppe auch tatsächlich existieren, auch wenn sie deutlich unbekannter sind. Jetzt gibt es, den Vatikan kennen ja wiederum relativ viele. Ich könnte mir jetzt noch andere Geheimbünde vorstellen, die ja auch ganz offen als solche auftreten, die durchaus auch Macht ausüben, zum Beispiel die Geheimdienste.
Aber vielleicht kurz, um das zu erläutern, warum die Geheimdienste Machtinstitutionen sind. Also ich hatte neulich das Vergnügen, in Washington drei Menschen zu treffen, etwa so 40- 50-Jährige, ein älterer Herr und zwei Damen, die trugen Schilder, da stand drauf Embassy of the Federal Republic of Germany, also Botschaft. Und ich fragte die 80 sind hier von der deutschen Botschaft in Washington und die sagten, ne, wir sind nur Gäste der Botschaft, wir stammen da so aus der Nähe von München. Und ich hab dann so ein bisschen nachgebohrt und irgendwann haben sie dann zugegeben, dass sie vom BND sind. Und dann hab ich mit denen also eine philosophische Diskussion über die Notwendigkeit, also die Existenzberechtigung von Geheimdiensten angefangen. Und die haben mir das, die haben gesagt, dass das im Prinzip so ist, dass ein Geheimdienst oder die Geheimhaltung aus Staatsgründen eben sinnvoll ist, um Prozesse zu verlangsamen, damit man sie besser kontrollieren kann. Also sozusagen um Macht überhaupt zu ermöglichen, erst mal die Prozesse so zu verlangsamen, die gesellschaftlichen Entwicklungen, die Eskalation, die Streitereien und so weiter und so fort, indem man da also so ein Vakuum an Informationen schafft, dass sich erst langsam, dass es zwar nicht wirklich irgendwie hält, also die Prozesse fangen ja nicht an irgendwie aufzuhören, aber gewisse Eskalationen wird da verlangsabt und dann kann man eben besser kontrollieren, kann man besser Macht aufnehmen.
Okay, also du drifft das immer sehr ins Politische, das ist auch nicht schlecht, aber die CIA, um mal das populärste Beispiel herauszugreifen von Geheimdiensten, wie wirkt denn die Macht der CIA? Also was, ich meine sie ist ja offiziell einer Regierung unterstellt, die viele als sehr viel Machtvoller ansehen.
Also die CIA ist ja der Außengeheimdienst der USA und aktuelles Beispiel haben wir ja jetzt gerade im Irak Kurdistan Komplex, wo also die CIA ja ganz offensichtlich eine Station im nördlichen Kurdistan, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf hat, aufgebaut hat, um also einen Ahnenpropagandasender zu installieren, der also anti Saddam Husseinistische Prokabander da irgendwie benutzt und zum anderen haben die eben eine Menge Leute bezahlt, Kurden dafür bezahlt, dass sie eben mithelfen, diesen Sender aufrecht zu halten und also Widerstand gegen Saddam Hussein und seine irakischen Truppen zu machen. Und blöderweise ist das Ganze aber aufgeflogen, dadurch dass da eben es zu Militäreinsätzen gekommen ist und die Amerikaner haben sich da, also die vier Amerikaner, die da tatsächlich diese Station betrieben haben, die haben sich in aller Windeseide verpisst und haben dabei irgendwie ihre 50 Mithelfer zurückgelassen, von denen inzwischen glaube ich 45 ungefähr umgebracht worden sind, von den Irakis und die restlichen da noch irgendwie gerade so flüchten konnten. Und also das ist jetzt ein Beispiel, wo man ganz konkret sagen kann, was die so machen und was sie ansonsten machen, das weiß eigentlich kein Mensch so wirklich.
Jetzt ist es an der Zeit, unsere Hörer zu fragen, was sie meinen. Ihr seid jetzt gefragt, wer regiert die Welt? Wir wollen von euch wissen, wer, eurer Auffassung nach, die Welt regiert. Wir haben wieder unser Voting freigeschaltet und ihr habt die Möglichkeit, mit eurem Telefon dazu beizutragen, Klarheit zu schaffen, wer denn nun die wahren Drahtzieher auf diesem Planeten sind. Zunächst einmal die Telefonnummer, die ihr wählen müsst. Das ist 030-254492 und dann zwei weitere Ziffern, um das auszuwählen, was eurer Meinung nach das Mächtigste auf diesem Planeten ist. Da haben wir die 20, die Außerirdischen. Wenn ihr der Meinung seid, die UFOs waren schon immer die Mächtigsten und alle anderen haben dagegen gar keine Chance, dann wählt ihr die 20. Die 21 ist der Präsident der USA. Wenn ihr der Meinung seid, dass Bill Clinton nicht zu überbieten ist, was seine Mächtige auf diesem Planeten betrifft, dann ist die 21 eure Wahl. Auf der 22 liegt die CIA, die hat mir ja gerade, die Central Intelligence Agency, der größte Geheimdienst. Auf die 22. Und wenn ihr der Meinung seid, die Illuminaten sind die Mächtigsten auf diesem Planeten, dann bleibt euch natürlich nur die 23. Das haben wir uns noch gar nicht erläutert, Frank. Auf 24 der Vatikan, auf der 25 dürfen wir natürlich nicht vergessen, die Banken, die 26 die Geschäftsleute, die Geschäftstreibenden an sich, wenn ihr also der Auffassung seid, dass die Wirtschaft noch sehr viel mehr Macht ausübt als all die anderen Organisationen, die 26. Und eigentlich sollte es ja so sein, 27 das Volk, das Volk übt die Macht auf diesem Planeten aus. Für die religiösen Fanatiker haben wir die 28 eingerichtet, die sind der Auffassung, dass Gott nach wie vor die Zügel fest in der Hand hält und für unsere Freunde die 29 hier regiert das Chaos. So, da ist wieder das Chaosradio. Wir haben noch einen Anrufer. Wer bist du? Hallo Franz. Was hast du für uns?
Ja, ich hätte eigentlich hier schon mal ein paar Anmerkungen zu machen, zu diesen wilden Shia Büchern, die hier ja laufend zitiert werden. Also ich denke schon, dass es hier schon eine ganze Reihe Querbezüge zur Scientology gibt und zwar wird ja in diesen Büchern doch auch öfters mal auf diesen Gründer von dieser Scientology Kirche hin und hin gewesen, wenn ich das noch so richtig im Kopf hab. Ich hab's jetzt zwar jetzt nicht.
Den Hubbard?
Ja.
Hab ich nicht im Kopf, aber red weiter.
Was soll ich weiter reden?
Nee, ich meine jetzt mal kommt...
Also, worauf es mir auch noch ankommt, bei diesen Illuminatengeschichten, es sieht mir immer so ein bisschen nach aus, als ob hier so ein Weltbild existiert. Es gibt jemanden, der irgendwo die ganze Geschichte kontrollieren kann, ob jetzt im gelben Unterseeboot oder sonst irgendwie. Das heißt so eine Art Geschichte vom guten Diktator, um halt jetzt so ein Schlagwort reinzubringen.
Also ich habe heute im Flieger ein sozusagen soziologisches Buch über Verschwörungstheorien gelesen und die behaupten genau das Gegenteil. Die sagen, dass die Leute, die Verschwörungstheorien machen, glauben, sich das so einfach machen zu können, indem sie sagen, die sind schuld an allem Elend dieser Welt. Und das ist sozusagen eigentlich das Gegenteil von dem, was du jetzt gerade sagst.
Das muss ich mal jetzt genauer erklären.
Naja, weil guck mal, die Illuminaten sind ja nicht die guten, das sind ja die Bösen. Und der Kampf gegen die Illuminaten ist dann natürlich eher wieder die gute Sache und so weiter und so fort. Und du sagtest jetzt eben, dass das irgendwie das Bild des guten Diktators ist. Und da, glaube ich, besteht ein Missverständnis, weil darum geht es überhaupt nicht. Im Gegenteil, das sind die bösen Diktatoren, die sich noch nicht mal als solche zu erkennen geben.
Das muss ich auch mal ganz klar in eurer Stelle mal ganz klar sagen. Ich denke, da existiert in diesen Illuminatenbüchern auch, wird so eine Mystifizierung, also wird so ein Mythos erzeugt. Und den macht ihr doch im Moment gerade auch in der Sendung, so eine Art Mythos zu erzeugen, was irgendwie gut wäre oder was irgendwo weiterhelfen würde. Und da denke ich, muss man dann mal ganz klar sagen, dass so ein guter Diktator oder irgendjemand, der irgendwo versuchte, nicht mal eine Ordnung ins Chaos, das will ich gar nicht mal sagen, sondern irgendwo einen Weg führen, dass es irgendwo was Gutes ist. Ich denke mal gegen diese Illuminatenbücher von Schere und Wilson, ich habe die mit groß Begeisterung gelesen und ich habe da auch ein Teil von irgendwo mit aufgenommen, aber ich finde es daneben, was da drin gesagt wird.
Weißt du, was das Schöne an Verschwörungstheorien ist? Für jeden sind sie ein bisschen anders.
Jeder versteht die ganzen Sachen immer anders.
Du ziehst sie auf eine falsche Ebene runter.
Nee, das glaube ich auch nicht. Also ich würde das anders beantworten wollen, aber das ist auch wieder nur eine philosophische Aussage und ich weiß nicht, ob ich dich damit glücklich mache. Zwei Aussagen, es gibt keinen Freund, nirgendwo. Es gibt keinen Feind. Moment, Entschuldigung, der andere Satz ist, es gibt keinen Feind, nirgendwo.
Es gibt sehr wohl Feinde.
Wer wäre denn deiner Meinung nach zum Beispiel eingefallen?
Es gibt eine ganze Menge Feinde.
Aber wenn du jemanden als Feind definierst, dann begebst du dich gleichzeitig auf die Ebene einer Prophezeiung, nämlich einer Self-fulfilling Prophecy. Wenn du sagst, jemand ist dein Feind.
Entschuldigung, das ist mit der Self-fulfilling.
Selbst nicht selbst erfüllenden Prophezeiung. Ich weiß, ich kann jetzt wahrscheinlich keine Aussage treffen, die dich richtig glücklich macht. Ich gebe zu, all das ist... Das ist nicht darum, mich glücklich zu machen. Natürlich sind all die...
Das, was ihr im Moment gerade macht mit der Sendung, das ist ein bisschen auf ein anderes Niveau zu drücken.
Ja gut, aber natürlich sind alle Verschwörungstheorien mit Vorsicht zu genießen. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es kein Verbrechen, seinen Gedanken einfach mal freien Lauf zu lassen. Gut, dann versuchen wir mal damit jetzt weiterzumachen.
Nee, ja, aber mit der Bezug auf Scientology möchte ich schon noch mal sagen, dass wir noch ein bisschen drauf nehmen sollen.
Moment, dieser Habert-Geschichte, nur kurz zur Klarstellung. Ich hab die gesamte Wilson Literatur hier vor mir liegen. Diese Habert-Geschichte kommt in eigentlichen Illuminatus-Büchern nur sehr am Rande vor. In den anderen Teilen, im Moment in den anderen Teilen, in den Schrödingers Katzebüchern von Wilson hatte er in den Brieftauben so ein schönes Wortspiel, wo er von einer Präsidentin Habert redet. Allerdings ist in diesem Buch, benutzt er so ziemlich einen Namen von allem und jedem und verwirrt sie dermaßen, um halt klarzustellen, dass Namen und die damit verbundene Gedanken halt nur in deinem Kopf existieren und dass du auch diese Dinge willkürlich ändern kannst, wenn du weißt, wie es geht.
Mir geht es gar nicht mal so sehr um den Namen Habert. Sondern es geht mir schon ein bisschen mehr darum, dass in diesen Illuminatenbüchern ein gut Teil von dem war Scientology. Also ich will jetzt, Scientology gehört sich gerade als Totschlagargument an. Gut, nehmen wir es zurück. Ja, sondern in dem Sinn, dass hier so eine Art Ichbezogenheit rüberkommt, die ich denke, die muss nicht sein. Also ich denke, der Mensch ist ein Gemeinschaftstier.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ja, und das muss irgendwo auch repräsentiert sein. Und das ist genau in den Illuminatenbüchern nicht repräsentiert.
Gut, das ist richtig, dass das ein bisschen egozentriker Literatur ist.
Ja, das ist ein ziemliches, individualistisches Teil.
Aber gib uns noch ein bisschen Zeit, weil wir greifen das mit der Scientology ohnehin nachher noch auf. Da haben wir was vorbereitet. Aber wir hatten uns eine kleine Dramaturgie überlegt und das wäre jetzt ein bisschen zu früh, okay?
Okay, wir wollen noch ein paar andere Leute mit reinnehmen. Okay, danke, dass du angerufen hast. Wir haben jetzt noch den Robert. Hallo Robert, bist du noch dran? Hallo. Was hast du für uns mitgebracht? Der regiert das Militär mit?
Aber wer bestimmt denn die Entscheidungen des Militärs?
Oder glaubst du, dass das Militär die Entscheidungen selber trifft?
Ja, im Großen und Ganzen, ja, sowohl so als Schein, als Fiskante, wird vielleicht dann, wie der Frau Dugendt immer gesagt, macht doch mal bitte so, in der Realität.
Klingt so ein bisschen plausibel. Also kann ich jetzt nichts gegen sagen.
Das ist dermaßen plausibel, das haben wir glaube ich schlicht vergessen. Haben wir noch eine Nummer frei im Voting?
Das kann man leider nicht mehr ändern.
Aber das ist denke ich ein Gesichtspunkt, den wir echt übersehen haben, oder?
Das Militär. Na ja, nun haben wir ja oft den Fall, dass das Militär putscht und die Macht übernimmt und von daher durchaus einen eigenen Machtfaktor stellt. Ob das Militär allerdings selbst die Welt als solche vollständig regiert, das sehe ich eher nicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Haben wir nicht neulich alle zusammen Independence Day geguckt? Nein, haben wir nicht.
Jetzt hast du es verraten.
Ich hab mich diesem Wahnsinn nicht angeschlossen. Aber war das nicht so, dass das Militär da immer nur gemacht hat, was sie gerade wollten? Also insofern finde ich das gar nicht so. Oder ist dieser Film nicht repräsentativ?
Überhaupt nicht.
Ach so.
Eine reine Funktion sozusagen.
Ja. Ja, fühlst du dich beantwortet? Alles klar, vielen Dank.
Vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, haben wir jetzt noch Hörer?
Wir haben noch ein paar Anrufe, da ist Simon nochmal wieder. Den sollten wir vielleicht nochmal kurz reinholen.
Ja, ansonsten sollten wir noch zur Frage der Stunde kommen.
Danach kommen wir dann zur Frage der Stunde. Sehr viel mehr Zeit haben wir nicht. Nochmal die Eins. Hallo Simon. Okay, wir haben dich vorhin irgendwie rausgewirkt. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das passiert ist. Du warst nochmal bei dem Thema der Illuminaten. Genau.
Also hier wurde ja angesprochen, die Illuminat-Design jetzt von Adam Weishaupt irgendwie gegründet.
Richtig.
Das stimmt im Sohanai nicht, denn 1770 hat der Herr Rothschild den Adam Weishaupt beauftragt, in Ingolstadt den Geheimorden der Bayerischen Illuminati zu gründen. Und die eigentlichen Illuminati haben die Bruderschaft der Schlange in Meso-Biotamien infiltriert.
Welche Literatur beziehst du dich?
Ich beziehe mich auf die Literatur, Geheimgesellschaften und ihre Macht aus dem 20.
Jahrhundert Jahren von Helsing.
Das ist wunderbar.
Das fehlt uns hier gerade, oder?
Ich hab das hier vor, ja. Natürlich.
Da haben wir es gerüstet.
Ja, ein Buch, was in Deutschland erstaunlicherweise indiziert wurde, weil der Herr von Helsing irgendwie dämlicherweise diese notorischen Protokolle der Elder von Zion zitiert hat. Ja, es ist eine der möglichen Ansichten zu diesem Punkt, da die Illuminaten aber dafür bekannt sind, dass sie erstens die Geschichtsschreibung gerne manipulieren und zweitens sich auch reichlich Frontorganisationen zulegen, die dann wieder so tun, als wären sie die echten Illuminaten. Und es ja zudem auch noch Hinweise gibt, dass die eigentlichen Herrsche der Welt nicht die Illuminaten, sondern eine geheime Organisation ohne Namen sind. Na ja, kann man es halt nur als eine weitere Theorie betrachten.
Die Wahrheit ist eine Glaubensfrage. Im Übrigen ist alles immer ganz anders.
Ja, aber was mich ja auch stört, das wird ja dauernd von den Illuminaten gesprochen. Aber jetzt klar, wer dahinter steht, das wird ja angesprochen.
Ich meine, wir haben ja immerhin schon mal eine konkrete Personenvorschlagsliste geliefert bis hin zum amerikanischen Vizepräsidenten. Das kann man nun teilen oder nicht teilen. War dir das zu wenig konkret?
Ja, also ich möchte hier noch vielleicht einen Rat der 13, Decan-Orient, Pneibrit, vielleicht die Rothschilds als Gesamte.
Aber die Rothschildtheorie, die, ähm, ja...
Oder die Jason-Gruppe.
Ja, die Rothschilds sind natürlich Klassiker, ne? Also Rothschild Morgen und so und Council of Foreign Relations.
Also das Problem ist, die Liste könnte man relativ beliebig erweitern. Also ich hab dann hier auch noch irgendwie eine Theorie über die eigentliche Macht der Stasi, dass die also sozusagen viel weitergeht. Und ich denke, wir würden uns da verlaufen. Wir haben uns Folgendes überlegt, vielleicht darf ich da jetzt so direkt zu übergehen für diese zweite Stunde, damit es eben nicht so ausufert, weil das könnte man in der Tat, das kann man dann vielleicht in der dritten Stunde machen. Wir wollen jetzt mal einen ganz konkreten Vorfall, der sich in letzter Zeit zugetragen hat. Nicht nur hier im Studio untersuchen, sondern wir wollen die Hörer fragen, was glaubt ihr, wie war es? Und wir möchten, dass ihr sozusagen mal mit dem bisschen, was ihr vielleicht jetzt an Vormaterial habt, oder was ihr ohnehin...
Dann müssen wir uns erstmal von Simon verabschieden.
Achso, Entschuldigung.
Simon, danke, dass du angerufen hast. Wir werden sicherlich noch oft auf das ein oder andere Thema zu sprechen kommen. Danke, tschüss.
So, vielleicht erst die Zahl 23 oder erst die Geschichte?
Erst die Geschichte.
Gut, also am 17. Juli dieses Jahres ist eine Maschine der Gesellschaft TVA, wie der eine oder andere schon gehört hat, auf dem Flug von New York nach Paris unmittelbar sozusagen noch in New Yorker Gebiet bei Long Island abgestürzt. Dabei kamen 230 Menschen ums Leben. Die Zahl 23 werden wir nachher noch erklären, was das damit auf sich hat. Nun gab es einiges hin und her, wie diese Maschine, also an Theorien, wie diese Maschine runtergekommen ist. Es gibt bisher kein amtliches Ergebnis. Nachdem zunächst ein Augenzeuge von einer Rakete berichtet hatte, wurde das dann wieder gesagt, dass das Quatsch sei. Dann gab es irgendwie die Theorie, dass es da einen mechanischen Defekt gab. Also die sind immer noch dabei, die Teile aus dem Ozean zu fischen und das Ding zu rekonstruieren und sich also zu überlegen, wie es gewesen sein könnte. Dabei hat sich ein Problem ergeben, nachdem jetzt einmal oder an mehreren Stellen Sprengstoffspuren gefunden wurden und also damit eigentlich klar schien, es war doch eine Bombe, kam dann auf einmal durch eine andere Untersuchung zutage, dass also die Maschine selbst zu Sprengstoffversuchen benutzt wurde. Also dazu da Sprengstoff zu platzieren und Hunde durchzuschicken, damit die das finden. Angeblich. Also wie gesagt, das war nachdem erst gesagt wurde, es war eine Bombe, dann hat es noch mal eine lückenlose Aufklärung aller Aufenthaltsorte der Maschine gegeben. Und dabei stellte sich dann heraus, dass da also ein Sprengstoffmanövertest mit Hunden durchgeführt worden sei.
Vorher war es ja so, dass angeblich damit noch GIs durch die Gegend geflogen wurden.
In den Golfkrieg.
Genau, die auch irgendwie Sprengstoff bei sich geführt haben sollen. Und die Theorie mit der Rakete war auch noch nicht so ganz aus der Welt.
Ja, und also mittlerweile ist es jetzt so, dass einer der Leiter der Untersuchungen des FBI, des amerikanischen BKA sozusagen gesagt hat, dass mit dieser Geschichte, mit dem Bombentest, dass sie da Hunde durchgeschickt haben und dass umhin mit dieser Maschine Sprengstoff schon befördert wurde und so weiter und fort sei es also schlicht unmöglich jetzt noch jemals darauf zu hoffen, da jemals objektiv festzustellen, was da passiert ist. Weil das einfach so viele Spuren da jetzt irgendwie verunmöglich zu verifizieren, das kann man einfach vergessen. Und damit ist es einfach offen. Auch wenn da jetzt noch weiter untersucht wird und vielleicht uns irgendwann ein amtliches Endergebnis präsentiert wird, frei nach dem Motto, es besteht zu keinem Zeitpunkt eine Gefahr für die Bevölkerung, ist die Frage sozusagen offen. Und die offen ist nicht nur für uns, sondern auch für euch. Ich habe da noch ein kleines Detail. Am Dienstag, den 23. Juli 1996, waren von den 230 Toten genau 123 schon geboren worden. Also es mag makaber sein, aber am 23. Juli 123 Toten von 230. Das ist irgendwie merkwürdig. Wir müssten jetzt eigentlich noch die 23 erläutern.
Wir erläutern das jetzt erstmal nicht. Jetzt spielen wir nochmal die Musik an. An euch geht erstmal, ich weiß, es sind jetzt noch ein paar Leute, die noch auf der Leitung hängen. Wir wollen uns jetzt allerdings doch mehrheitlich auf dieses Fallbeispiel TWA 800 beziehen. Das heißt, wir wollen von euch Verschwörungstheorien hören. Wir wollen eure Version der Geschichte hören. Wir werden es auch selber noch ein paar machen. Wir haben eben ein paar Fakten schon geliefert. Die Liste geht, glaube ich, noch ein bisschen weiter. Ich weiß ja auch nicht, was ihr alles noch gehört habt. Ich habe noch gehört, dass noch ein berühmter Fotograf in der Maschine gesessen hat, der gestorben ist. Da sind auch wieder solche Sachen. Irgendjemand hat UFOs gesehen und es gab die Theorie, dass das Ding durch eine Stairsmaschine abgeschossen wurde. Das alles wollen wir nach der Musik ausführlich theoretisieren. Chaosradio auf Radio Fritz. Wir sind bei den Verschwörungstheorien diesmal angelangt. Wir haben nach wie vor noch ein Voting laufen unter der Nummer 030254492 und dann zwei weitere Ziffern. Wir fragen euch nach, wer regiert die Welt? Wir haben euch zehn Möglichkeiten gegeben. Die 20, die Außerirdischen, die 21, der Präsident der USA, die CIA auf der 22, die Illuminaten auf der 23, der Vatikan auf der 24, die Banken auf der 25, die Geschäftstreibenden auf der 26, das Volk regiert die Welt auf der 27, Gott regiert die Welt auf der 28 und auf der 29 regiert das Chaos. Wir sind jetzt bei TWA 800, diesem sagenumwobenen Flugzeugabsturz vor einigen Monaten, der bis heute noch nicht richtig aufgeklärt ist. Wir haben eben schon zahlreiche verschiedene Meldungen gehört, die durch die Nachrichten gegeistert sind, das nimmt auch in dem Sinne gar kein Ende. Was ist denn eigentlich, Frank, was ist denn deine Meinung? Ich meine, das Ding ist einfach explodiert, was ist da jetzt passiert?
Also ich fahre persönlich die Theorie, wonach unter der Sitzreihe 23 eine kleine Bombe gelegen hat, die das Luft-Treibstoff-Gemisch im nicht gefüllten Haupttank entzündet hat. Und dass vielleicht der oder die Attentäter so clever waren, sich eine Maschine auszusuchen, von der sie wussten, dass vorher damit Sprengstoff transportiert wurde, sodass hinterher nicht mehr nachzuweisen ist, wer es war.
Und wozu diente das Ganze dann?
Sie wollten halt einfach Zwietracht und Chaos sehen.
Ja und wer war das dann?
Tja, vielleicht die irisierische Befragungsbewegung?
Also ich hab vorhin in einem Buch gelesen, dass wenn man das Chaos eskanieren lassen will, dann unterstützt man am besten jegliche politische Gruppierung, sowohl links als auch rechtsextreme gleichermaßen.
Naja, ich mein, das haste ja nur getan mit diesem Anschlag. Naja, überleg doch einfach. Naja, jeder beschuldigt jeden.
Das ist ja wohl das Allerletzte.
Es getan zu haben und ich meine, die Platzierung kurz vor Olympia war einfach, naja.
Ja, also das scheint mir nicht plausibel, muss ich mal sagen. Ich weiß nicht, haben wir von der Faktenlage da noch Einwürfe aus der Mitte hier? Fakten, ich trau mich überhaupt nicht von Fakten zu sprechen.
Ich hab hier ungefähr 50, 60 Seiten mit DPA-Meldungen zum Thema, die sich alle durchweg widersprechen.
Einmal wird hier geschraubt, keine Bestätigung gab es heute, das war am 23. Juli für die Medienberichte, nachdem auf einem Flügelteil der Boeing Spuren chemischer Rückstände gefunden worden seien. Später wieder heißt es, sei also sicher davon auszugehen, dass eine Bombe an Bord gewesen sei, mit nahezu 100%iger Sicherheit. Dann heißt es wieder am 23. August, immer kommen solche Meldungen am 23.
Merkwürdig, am Donnerstag hatte Robert Francis bereits vor einer Explosion im Bereich des mittleren Treibstofftanks gesprochen. Da ist also der Treibstofftank fast sicher explodiert.
Dann wurde es doch nicht endgültig. Also das, was auf jeden Fall explodiert ist, ist die Menge an Informationen über diesen Vorfall. Genau, das ist der Punkt. Es geht dabei, wenn nicht irgendetwas sei es noch so peinlich, ob das Ding jetzt nun aus Versehen runtergefallen ist, ob es explodiert ist, ob es abgeschossen wurde, was auch immer. Was daran interessant ist, entweder soll es vertuscht werden, ganz gleich, was es war, und das tut man am besten dadurch, dass man so viel wie möglich verschiedene Theorien in Umlauf bringt, oder aber es weiß einfach wirklich keiner.
Das sind so die zwei wesentlichen Möglichkeiten. Naja, also ich meine, die Vertuschung begann ja schon ganz am Anfang. Die erste Theorie war ja, dass das Flugzeug mit einer Stinger-Rakete abgeschossen wurde, was dann sofort dementiert wurde mit der Begründung, eine Stinger-Rakete könnte nicht so hoch fliegen. Also Stinger sind diese kleinen Raketen, die man sich auf die Schulter lädt, um irgendwelche Flugzeuge abzuschießen. Und eine kurze Recherche im Internet ergab dann, dass es sehr wohl auf der Schulter tragbare Raketen gibt, die auch noch doppelt so hoch fliegen können, wie dieses Flugzeug zu dieser Zeit geflogen ist. Von daher war dieses Dementi schon mal eine glatte Lüge.
Ja, aber was sagen die Hörer? Ich will jetzt wissen, was die Hörer sagen.
Was sagen die Hörer? Was meinen die Hörer? Wieso ist dieses Flugzeug runtergefallen? Wir haben übrigens noch eine E-Mail gekriegt. Flattert hier gerade rein.
Von dem Ole, der fragt uns, ob wir das eigentlich alles wirklich ernst meinen. Ach, das machen wir dann in der dritten Stunde. Da sendieren wir dann da drüber. Ich gebe das nachher noch mal zum Besten.
Tim, was haben wir denn für Hörer?
Ja, ich würde gerne noch einen Hörer reinnehmen, aber leider müssen wir den Bedingungen dieses Radiosenders gerecht werden und um halb nochmal...
Es gibt wieder viele Informationen aus aller Welt.
Hörerstheorien von überall her.
Aber wir können ja vielleicht kurz die Zeit noch nutzen, die wir haben, um endlich mal die Sache mit der 23 aufzuklären. Ihr merkt sicherlich die ganze Zeit, dass wir besondere Begeisterung immer für diese Zahl empfinden. Unsere Pizzas, die wir heute bestellt haben, haben insgesamt 23 Mark gekostet. Das hat uns genauso sehr überrascht, wie dass der Stau auf der Autobahn genau beim Kilometer 23 war. Dann war auch Johnny nicht mehr da. Das Thema zieht irgendwie seine Spuren. Was hat es denn damit auf sich, Frank? Mach doch mal kurz.
Frank, jetzt bist du dran. Das ist ziemlich schwierig. Auf jeden Fall ist das irgendwie die Zahl der Illuminaten. So viel steht ungefähr fest. Vielleicht können wir es wissenschaftlicher leiten.
Es ist nicht wissenschaftlicher zu leiten. Es ist nur so, dass diese Zahl erstaunlich oft auftritt in dieser Welt. Und dass sie umso öfter auftritt, je mehr man sich mit ihr beschäftigt. Und in die Welt gerufen wurde dieser 23er Mythos tatsächlich von Robert Anton Wülsen, soweit ich das überblicke. Ja, die Illuminaten selbst. Gut, vielleicht waren es auch die Illuminaten selbst. Ja, die Bedeutung ist halt, die ist halt wichtig.
Alles klar, dann wollen wir jetzt auf das Fritz-Kurz-Hinfo umscheiden. TWA 800 ist am, wie viel der Juli? Das war aber nicht der 23.
Ja, hallo, hallo, das war der 17.
wenn ich da richtig informiert bin. Und im Flur wurde ich eben informiert, dass gerade nach einem Hörereinwand kamen, in unserer Liste, wer regiert die Welt, haben wir die Liebe vergessen.
Oh, ja, wir sind echt so, dass wir müssen...
Männer dominierte Scheißveranstaltungen sein. Also, ne, das ist aber jetzt echt wüst, ne?
Also ich hab, da passt auch diese E-Mail rein, die meinte, Kreativität regiert die Welt, oder habt ihr zu viel Civilization gespielt? Find ich auch einen echt guten Einwand, muss ich jetzt echt mal sagen.
Wir gehen jetzt in uns, tschüss.
Okay, dann wollen wir doch mal unsere Hörer mal fragen, was wir da... Ja genau, Hörer, mach doch mal......Theorien zu der TWA 800 haben. Hallo, wer bist du, Gregor?
Ja, ich bin Gregor, wunderbar.
Du hängst schon eine Weile in der Leitung, glaube ich.
Ja, ja, aber ich meine, die Telekom, die macht ja sozusagen um diese Zeit doch gar nicht mal so schlechte Tarife mehr, nicht?
Aha, ein Blut.
Egal, auch eine kleine Verschwörung für sich, diese Preispolitik der Telekom.
Hast du denn eine Verschwörung für uns bezüglich des abgestürzten Flugzeugs?
Nein, also ich wollte sozusagen mal ein bisschen diskutieren, warum das denn sozusagen immer diesen Bedarf für Informationen gibt, also dass sozusagen Ereignisse irgendwo erklärt werden wollen, vielleicht erklärt werden können von einigen, die das vielleicht nicht zugeben wollen, und auf der anderen Seite eben auch vielleicht auch bestimmte Sachen nicht einfach klären können, was da aber auch wieder nicht eingestehen können. Weil Information auch wieder eine Machtfrage ist. Und der Zugang zu Informationen.
Ja, jetzt kommen wir aber echt mal auf den Punkt. Das finde ich gut. Nochmal weiter.
Und so wie mir das sich sozusagen mal aufgefallen ist, ist es ja eigentlich immer eine Frage, wenn jetzt jemand Macht hat und Information hat, zum Beispiel, es war vielleicht ein ungeliebter Ex-Drogendealer von der CIA, ein Flugzeug, der nun auf unerfällige Weise beseitigt werden sollte, so wird das keiner inneren Bevölkerung der USA innerhalb der nächsten 50 bis 100 Jahre erfahren. Die entsprechenden Leute in den Kreisen, die vielleicht Zugang zu irgendwelchen Leuten haben, die so etwas arrangieren könnten, die wissen das ziemlich genau. Und du sagst, du hättest keine echt coole Verschwörungstheorie zum TWA-Resturz? Nein, das ist aber ein rein hypothetisch... Nein, Theorien sind immer hypothetisch. Das ist völlig klar. Ich meine, aber war da nicht diese Geschichte mit der Estonia, die genau angeblich wegen sowas auch abgesoffen ist, weil da irgendwelche Gedrogen an Bord gewesen sein sollen, die dann zwar nicht an Bord waren, aber dafür war was anderes an Bord, was dann über Bord musste mit LKW, wo sie die Klappe aufgemacht haben, um den LKW über Bord zu kippen und dabei ist das Ding abgesoffen. War doch auch so eine Geschichte, ne? Ja, natürlich, natürlich. Ich meine, im Endeffekt ist es doch einfach eine Machtfrage. Ja, also Wissen ist Macht.
Genau, in jedem Fall ist es absolut Macht.
Und wer diese Macht nicht hat, nämlich sozusagen wir einfach, die hier am Radio sitzen und uns irgendwelche Nachrichten über zum Beispiel unseren Radiosender anhören und wenn das so ein Ding runtergekommen ist, wir fragen uns, ach Gott, die Armen.
Ich meine, es ist ja auch eine Menge Leid mit so etwas verboten.
Ja, natürlich.
Und das Problem ist für uns, dass wir uns irgendwelche Erklärungsmuster bauen müssen.
Was eigentlich passiert ist und warum das so passiert ist. Ja, und zwar je weniger Informationen wir haben, oder je mehr widersprechende Informationen wir haben, umso wüster werden diese Theorien und so eher sind wir geneigt, Dinge zu glauben, die wir normalerweise mit gesunden Menschverstand gar nicht glauben würden.
So, das ist auf einer Seite ein total kreativer Faktor, auf der anderen Seite kratzt es natürlich ganz stark an diesem Begriff Wahrheit. Also ich denke, dass du da möchtest, du eigentlich auch drauf raus.
Genau, das ist nämlich genau der, also gut, ich hab das jetzt nicht mit dem Begriff Wahrheit gemacht, sondern mit dem Begriff Information eben, weil ja mit dem, in der Art und Weise, wie uns dieser Zugang zu dieser Information verweigert wird, wir uns ja auch jeglicher Handlungsmöglichkeit entziehen oder diese auch uns entzogen wird. Ganz genau, das ist die Rolle von Geheimdiensten, wie ich schon erwähnte, Prozessversammlung, Wartausübung. Die Frage ist, wir haben jetzt aber ein Problem. Wir haben jetzt theoretisch das Internet, ein Medium, was frei von Zensur ist und was also theoretisch zumindest die technische Informationsblukade sehr schwierig macht. Das Problem, das wir haben, ist...
Entschuldigung, gerade um aufs Internet zu kommen, ich hab mich mal gefragt, warum jetzt diese ganze Kinderpornografie-Debatte so hochgetreten wird, in der letzten Zeit in den Medien. Und warum wird das hochgetreten?
Weil damit wir natürlich in diese Medien, die all die ganzen Sachen so schön verbreiten, wo sozusagen unilaterale, also ein... Unkontrollierter. Unkontrollierter Zugriff von einem Land, wo ein einziges Land alleine nicht zugreifen kann, muss eben eine Weltöffentlichkeit her, die Bubu sagt, damit die Autoritäten sich da einfügen können und sagen können, okay, wir regeln das alles. Wir schließen diese Tür zu, wir kontrollieren das alles und wir machen das alles. Ich meine, das ist doch im Prinzip genau das gleiche wie mit den ganzen Schrifierungsgeschichten und so weiter und so fort.
Und was ist deine Theorie zu dem Flugzeugabsturz?
Hat er doch schon gesagt.
Die Theorie zum Flugzeugabsturz, ja. Also, mein Gott, da kann ich dir jetzt ganz definitiv nichts sagen, was denn nun genau gelaufen ist.
Das könnte ich dir auch nicht sagen.
Tim, ich finde das auch berechtigt, dass man auch mal nichts sagen darf, wenn man irgendwie nichts Sinnvolles zu sagen hat. Also, verstehst du, dann sind wir wieder beim Faktor. Wo man nicht sprechen kann, muss man einfach schweigen.
Zumal die Addition von Rauschen ja auch ein beliebtes Mittel ist, um Informationen zu unterdrücken.
Also ich habe heute in einem Münchner Licht- also Lampenladen gegenüber dem Hauptbahnhof gelesen, wenn wir doch alle nur etwas mehr schweigen und etwas mehr verstehen könnten. Und das fand ich einen guten Satz und deswegen, ich finde das durchaus berechtigt, wenn er sich zum Flugzeugabsturz nicht äußern möchte.
Ist ja auch völlig in Ordnung. Ok, Gregor, dann wollen wir mal weiterschalten. Vielen Dank, dass du angerufen hast.
Ich kann hier eine Hörer endlich auflegen.
Hast schon ein heißes Ohr her.
Ok, bis dann, ciao. So, wen haben wir als nächstes auf der Liste? Hallo. Haben wir erstmal keinen mehr? Haben alle wieder aufgelegt?
Kommt fast keine Hörertheorien zum Flugzeugabsturz?
Na ja, vielleicht wollen die erstmal unsere Theorien hören. Bei so viel haben wir ja noch gar nicht gebracht. Ich meine, wir haben schon mal so langsam angefangen, was es denn theoretisch sein könnte. Und wenn man sich so die ganze Informationslage sein könnte, könnte es natürlich auch einen vollkommen anderen Grund haben. Ich meine, klar, hätten die Amerikaner da die Maschine abschließen können.
Also wer hat ein Interesse daran, die Information zu vertuschen? Wenn es natürliche Ursache war, dann hat a. der Flugzeughersteller und b. die betreibende Fluggesellschaft Interesse daran, das nicht rauszudrücken. Dass es also einfach mal vorkommt, dass so etwas vom Himmel fällt.
Das sind ja jetzt gar nicht die, die alleine ermitteln.
Also ermitteln ja noch mehr, es ermitteln ja tatsächlich.
Ja, bloß die Ermittler sind doch irgendwie tatsächlich nur mal eine nette Machtstruktur von daher. Ja, aber ich weiß nicht inwieweit jetzt z.B.
die Machtstrukturen unterwandert sind von den Fluggesellschaften, so dass sie verhindern könnten, dass die Ermittlung ordentlich geführt wäre.
Boeing ist irgendwie nun nicht gerade eine sehr kleine Company. Von daher wäre halt zu überlegen, ob Boeing vielleicht schon irgendwie Mittel und Wege hat, da sie ein strategischer Teil der US-Industrie sind, derartige Dinge zu unterbinden, dass sowas auskommt, dass es tatsächlich einen mechanischen Fehler gab.
Also als ich neulich in Usa war, da haben sie auf CNN, also auf amerikanischen CNN, es gibt da drei oder vier verschiedene CNN, haben sie eine dreiviertel Stunde ununterbrochen, so eine Pressekonferenz eben live gesendet, wo sich der Leiter der Ermittlung des FBIs und der von dieser Flughafenaufsichtsbehörde neben einem Techniker eben den Fragen der Presse stellen musste. Und also die Jungs haben sich wirklich bemüht, also ich glaube, spätestens nach einer halben Stunde konnten die ohnehin nicht mehr lügen, weil das war, also da waren eben auch Familien dabei, der Opfer, und das war schon ziemlich dramatische Inszenierung, die die da gebracht haben. Und da kam dann irgendwann die Frage, ja, werden wir dann überhaupt noch irgendwie eine Lösung kriegen, nachdem jetzt schon so viel hin und her war und so fort? Und ja, ich weiß nicht. Also wenn überhaupt, dann bestimmt das jemand anderes, dass die auch nichts erfahren, oder? Die Außerirdischen könnten mithilfe, oder der CIA könnte mithilfe Elektro, wie heißt das, Extrem Low Reflection, also es gibt so eine Menschemanipulationsmethode mit Elektronenstrahlen. Es könnte auch sein, dass die alle manipuliert sind. Ja, ich hab noch einen zu dem Thema, das ist jetzt echt kein Scherz, die Infektionen zurückzufordern.
Und zwar auf unserer Leitung Nummer 2.
Oh, bin ich dran?
Du bist on air.
Ich bin gerade dran.
Pass auf, das war die Maschine auch.
Bisschen uneindeutig, ob man dran ist oder nicht.
Kann ich fürstern.
Ich hab zwei Theorien.
Ja, mach mal.
Okay, dann erstmal die erste.
Das ist halt, es war wirklich ein Unfall. Kann ja passieren, dass irgendwas kaputt ging. Ein Funke, ein Knall und dann war das Ding im Meer.
Also zumindest gab es Berichte, die einen ähnlichen Fall dokumentiert haben, vor ein paar Jahren, wo auch eine Maschine noch stehend explodiert ist. Da wurde gesagt, das hätte den gleichen Grund haben können.
Die zweite Theorie?
Naja, ich wollte sagen... Das hätte den Film das Fliegen der Auge. Das sagt euch was, also vor so einem Großereignis passiert irgendwas, damit dann halt bestimmte Verbände, ob das eine Industrie ist oder eben Geheimdienste oder Militäre, noch so ein paar Millionen vom Senat bekommen. Und ich finde, so zeitlich hat das ja ganz gut gepasst. Und diese ganze Hysterie mit der Aufklärung und wer oder was das gewesen sein könnte, hat ja auch gehört, irgendwelche Iraner mal wieder, nachdem erst dieses Sprengstoffattentat...